Boston has not beaten Orlando since
October of 2022 here's 3D with the one
and only hulo B cars follow we get off
to a little slow start let's talk about
you guys as team defense on how you lock
down the Celtics tonight that's what we
take pride in that's our calling card
that's what it's been all year and uh
yeah I mean we just come in every game
one one game Focus you know what we got
to do to stop the team in front of us
and we did a good job tonight a lot of
young teams preach about being unselfish
but you you guys seem to really buy into
that chemistry wanting you guys to play
well each night yeah man for me I think
it's different when you really like
playing with the guys you with man like
everybody here love each other like real
genuine love so it's easy passing to the
next guy cuz you know he got your best
interest and uh we just got full 100%
trusting each other how much fun has it
been dagged a little extra excitement
with the in season tournament it's been
huge these two inseason tournament games
at at Amway been crazy so I'm glad we
got the win hopefully we in good
position to move on and uh I'm excited
keep doing what you do we love what you
do big fell appreciate your blessing the
way you're guarding the way you're
sitting down the way you're holding each
other accountable the way you're
communicating like stay greedy stay
greedy I want y'all to stay greedy y'all
doing the right thing you're defending
at a high ass clip and that's who we are
all right I'm so damn proud of y'all man
y'all just stay stay the
course stay greedy and move up look at
that point differential plus 22 in the
inseason tournament the Orlando Magic
not playing around and here's something
that paollo van Carol said we really
like playing the guys with that you're
with right and you look at the bench
points for the Orlando Magic 57 Mo
Vagner outscored the Celtics bench by
himself that's indicative of what
they're saying as a team and it's the
way they're getting it done it's almost
like have two starting units because
okay if the starting unit doesn't have
it going the second unit can come give a
lift you have starters come off that
bench Cole Anthony Wagner if you look
right here and how they're getting it
done two man game uh-oh I don't like
like it I'll redirect I'll be patient
I'll get to my spot get a shot up and
everything with them is just about how
they're getting it done Co Anthony again
navigating at the helm he'll get it back
take a three doesn't make the three but
watch the extra effort right here those
are winning plays that's worth more than
the two points because look at him beat
his chest let him know you got that done
and then right here navigating the horn
screen being very very patient it's
right now it's a two-on-one he took that
extra patient dribble as Zeke likes to
say drops it off keeps his teammates
involved
and when they're rolling like that with
how they're playing they basically
brought a college atmosphere to the pros
and they're all connected and the young
team playing like that with confidence
Zeke that's tough to deal with and and
the chemistry that they have and the way
they've bonded you know analytics don't
account for that yes but but you win
with good chemistry and talent and
that's what they have you know Zeke we
know how good the Boston Celtics have
been the last five or six years but the
Orlando Magic have beaten them in four
straight games why is that you know some
teams just have your number and and you
know they match up well at that Wing
position with Isaac banaro taking Brown
and Tatum so those are good two good
defensive matchups two good offensive
matchups so they hit the Celtics in all
of the right spots one thing though we
got to make sure we we we enunciate and
say holiday wasn't there today so we
don't know what effect he would have on
the game but him not being there is a
big loss for the Celtics yeah absolutely
so the Boston Celtics they lose to
Orlando Magic and again the magic have
won six in a
row